this
is wakana she's three years old and
she's playing with duplo blocks for the
first time
she's not making anything fancy but you
can already see that she kind of gets it
this is an industrial robot it can also
put things together piece by piece but
only because a human told it exactly how
put a pile of parts in front of the
robot and say make a car
and nothing much is going to happen
we humans have big dreams for our robots
we want them to look like us move like
us
and most importantly think like us
but we keep hitting a wall robots are
basically just computers and in some
pretty key ways
computers are dumber than
three-year-olds
so how do we get to a robot that can
start to think for itself
that was kind of fun to wash this it
could actually jam the cap in there it
would probably be interesting to watch
is it really strong enough for that yeah
well it'll
like completely destroy the cap in the
process but it'll get it in position
if you were trying to get a cap in a
bottle for 10 minutes you get pretty
frustrated too
this is brett berkeley robot
for the elimination of tedious tasks
brett is a robot that can think
the project we're looking at is seeing
if brett
can learn through its own trial and
error
this type of learning is called
reinforcement learning
you get rewarded if you do well
you get maybe penalized if you don't do
so well and over time you're
trying to figure out how to do better
and we're trying to get brett to learn
the same way
initially the robot starts out with very
little prior knowledge for example it
doesn't actually know
which of its motors control assurance
first it'll do it in a very clumsy way
just sort of fumbling around trying to
get
things in roughly the right arrangement
and as a practice more and more as it
refines its strategy the behavior
becomes more precise
you can think of this as a little bit
like the game of hot or cold it gets
sometimes it gets a little bit closer to
the goal sometimes it's a little bit
further away
essentially by attempting the task and
sometimes doing better and sometimes
doing worse it can figure out
what kinds of behaviors lead to success
more often
most robots are controlled by a string
of codes so they execute the same motion
over and over
without ever really changing or adapting
brett's different instead of a series of
commands
brett kind of has a brain the robot is
controlled by a large neural network
neural networks are a big deal in
artificial intelligence right now
so we decided to go talk to this guy
joshua benjio
he's one of the leading minds in
artificial intelligence and he actually
helped create some of the first neural
networks back in the 80s
one way to understand what neural
networks do
is to consider the analogy with what's
going on in the brain
what happens in brains is that the
neurons receive
signals that they send to other neurons
as you move forward in this chain the
brain is actually doing computation
to understand the world around us and
neural networks
imitate this process a neural network is
an algorithm made up of the computer
equivalent of neurons
not physical but virtual the network
takes on a problem
say trying to get this plane's landing
gear into that little hole
doesn't go so great at first so and this
is the key
the neural network basically rewrites
itself connecting different patterns of
neurons to get to the best solution
give it another try and there it is
the network learned and adapted all on
its own
no human intervention necessary
oh and by the way neural networks are
blowing up right now
robotics is kind of the least of it
neural nets are at the heart of just for
starters
google image search google translate
skype translator facial recognition on
facebook recommendations on facebook
handwriting recognition on checks
algorithms that can discover new
medicines and detect lung cancer most
voice recognition software microsoft's
cortana this algorithm that can play
video games
oh and this craziness which you might
have seen a project called
deep dream from the folks at google
brain
after the google brain team had built
these image recognition models
they then used these models to generate
synthetic images
this is bloomberg's neural networks guy
gideon man
and so these were pictures that they
colloquially
were saying that dineronet dreamed
it's not clear that uh artificial
intelligence
will be the same as the human
intelligence and it will probably
be a whole lot weirder than we expect
so do you think neural networks are
eventually going to be like the
equivalent of a human brain
it's hard to say how ai will be
in decades from now really hard even for
the best scientists that that work in ai
worrying about the singularity and
robots being
self-aware and everything is like
worrying about overpopulation on mars
we're still so far away from from
building something that's really
intelligent even though of course a lot
of progress has been made
i think the the jury's still out on kind
of
the nature of what an artificial
intelligence is going to look like
is it going to look like a human brain
and human intelligence is it going to
look
like something very different you know
even
somewhat sacrilegiously will it be more
evolved than us
will it be more ethical and moral than
us perhaps
brett's artificial brain still has a
long way to go
even before it catches up to wakana but
that's not necessarily going to keep it
from taking over the world
in a friendly sort of way
robots like brett that can figure stuff
out for themselves can escape those
monotonous factory jobs and find work in
less predictable environments
in the near future or the near-ish
future that could mean a lot more robots
helping us out in our homes offices
hospitals and nursing homes
beyond that who knows maybe someday
we'll have a robot that's
even smarter than a three-year-old it is
always fun to see what it comes up with
you